believe in yourself execute and just you
know and then and then think about
uh thanks tony robbins but think about
uh
tommy rob would you listen to [ __ ] i
know
he's like subtle like [ __ ] positive
he's like if you believe
and then i kept talking about things you
got to be selfish with the time
you got to be selling your time like all
right that has nothing to do with uh my
boy danny ricardo but we will power to
do this
why don't we just sit there he's like
every dream
every dream starts with a challenge i'm
like all right garyvee
shut it down dude i hate that
motivational [ __ ]
i hate it i hate it you hate that kind
of stuff i hate it
i thought you relate to it more
chappelle because you
like i read the self-help books but like
i don't know itself helps different it's
not telling you like
yeah like i take it for myself i'm not
sitting here like
yo you you could be this you could be
yeah but i don't know
yours like to motivate like but you're
not reading like gary vee's [ __ ] are you
no i never read this [ __ ] no
the [ __ ] i i like to read is like how to
just like be a better person be a better
person and take on your own [ __ ] like
whole responsibility
for yourself ownership that's what
that's what i read like i like to read
[ __ ] like that like
it makes it all about you it's not about
like this you know put your mind to it
like i can't i cannot
i hate getting into that [ __ ] because
it's so cliche and so obvious
you got another one your transgressions
i don't want to [ __ ] on people who like
that garyvee yeah because it does
that helps you i don't give a do it
exactly that's that's for me
it's like triggering what's like just
get it done
yeah can i that's how it looks well i'm
sorry what
motivates you brenden not now i'm just
asking because you say you know
like i can't even tell you you're like
if so because you have great drive
i've been around you
you don't think so i feel like they do
that'd be a weird thing to be like your
[ __ ] brittany i gotta sell everything
you're staying under the radar man
you're a type of dude really i think you
need to
outlandish about it like like i always
think of it like this it's like
like with religion i'm not religious
like if religion is that thing that
helps you
yeah stay grounded for
like your spirituality is per it's like
perfect that you don't have you don't
care about the outside noise because you
know who you are you're in tune with
yourself
you're a sagittarius
you use that sagittarius
but you know you don't have an idea of
like what just [ __ ] drives you just
yeah i know yeah i think you just have
it i i think so
i've had this [ __ ] fired me since i
was a kid
yeah like since i was a kid i always
felt
don't know what it is in different
nature yeah it's just like i i run hot
and yeah in my heart did you ever get
overlooked overlooking anything oh yeah
oh so that's big time chips like this
on your shoulders there's a [ __ ] pile
of pringles on my shoulder really
tons kettle chips and it started ever
since i was
like when i was younger started from
when i was on this
like i got into this like high level
like uh
aaa basketball team like this big league
basketball team and i was the only white
guy on the team
yeah and yeah it's not racist
the coach treated me like [ __ ] yeah and
i remember we all got
like we said like they we raised all
this money for new jerseys yeah and he
gave everybody jerseys except for me
and he yeah what and i have to wear my
old jersey while all my friends got
their new jerseys and i just oof
pisses me off i know right i feel it
right now i'm looking at her right now
no wait why did he so that's what i said
that's also why i'm a like uh
yeah just but ever since i was little
like always like those little things
like
jerseys and logos and like colors like i
was really into like fashion yeah so
that meant like it hurt my feelings so
bad
so yeah i was different but then there's
that and then
like in high school football like
finally when it was my time my senior
year
the first play of the season um we went
down to florida to play and they it
there's
the cornerback was had a full ride to
florida state and i was looking to go
somewhere big
like texas a m or cu or
cal like i i was going to go somewhere
big i was like i'm gonna start just
[ __ ] dude florida state watch this
so the coach called the first play a
deep pass to me
and that [ __ ] florida state player
picked the ball off
first play picked the ball off and i was
chasing them down to
i was going to strip them like all right
you got the ball i'm stripping it's
going to be dope
and he juked out our biggest defender
gary gary moore who was like six seven
350 pounds he juked him out and gary
missed and ran into me
and uh broke my ribs and lacerated my
liver no so i missed my entire
senior year season [ __ ] so i had to go
to a smaller college work my ass off
there and then go to division one yeah
as a walk-on
and then i was as talented i thought as
the rest of the scholarship players but
they treated me like [ __ ]
so same thing we were a nike school and
they would give
all the top players special shoes yeah
that's why i care so much about shoes
yeah they give all the top players
special shoes that never gave them to me
really but but but why though like it's
just like because i wasn't
i wasn't bobby purify or lawrence
vickers i wasn't on a scholarship at the
time
so you had to work for everything even
when you worked for they still
overlooked everything
and then balled out senior balled out
thought i was gonna get drafted
didn't got overlooked there so it's like
these chips
i get to the ufc you know so it's just
overlooked weird man
but you don't seem like you have a chip
on your shoulder no i uh
i don't like i'm not like i don't look
at other like comics or like podcasts
like i have no
it's just different with that i just
worry about my [ __ ] because you i mean
especially in our world like you can see
the chips heavy
yeah the people that have like no not
with you
their chips are different their chips
are they're not successful and they look
at other people and blame
their failures on other people because
they think
yeah or you're taking them out like
you're taking something from them
and that's their problem oh that's the
reason why i've had some comics say some
crazy [ __ ] to me yeah right
like i've had comments oh you only get
that because you're black not even
because they don't even
not even that i'm talented me too
because you're black that's
the like that's the [ __ ] like but like
you know that that stuff is oh that
that's
that's never gonna like yeah i would get
for the not too much now i'd get oh the
only reason
he sells tickets because he fought in
the ufc listen i was
i wasn't i don't think so anymore no no
one's coming
you still had to work hard to sell
tickets too you weren't selling tickets
immediately were you [ __ ] no
exactly so that's the the no you
constantly have to beat that narrative
like oh it's it's just uh
like a [ __ ] charlie sheen tiger blood
tour where you're yeah you know it's
just this kind of
act you know yeah like you couldn't go
back into a city and sell tickets if you
weren't funny
i remember i remember when uh when stevo
was on here he said he didn't sell
tickets immediately
and he was already [ __ ] super he's
already steve oh you know what i mean
like he's already
everybody he really doesn't work like
that that's what does people don't
understand it doesn't work like that you
can't just sell the tickets just saw the
justification of you've already had this
like name no you know like i couldn't go
to the if
if i didn't have some sort of talent and
comedy i couldn't get up at the comedy
store
exactly it would happen once and like
get the [ __ ] out like
the standard they're so high mm-hmm yeah
yeah yeah i was i was a little different
though like i mean i think what drove me
was like uh
i don't know i think i just don't want
to be a loser yeah i i i
got kids especially now you got kids
yeah don't there's nothing worse when
you're running
like an old friend like we're doing man
just and you tell you like god [ __ ]
and you just feel bad like you stopped
man you stopped the [ __ ] race
like it never stops exactly it never
stops it's like a [ __ ]
constant you you would you have a drive
yeah i wasn't
the i was wasn't the most talented guy
in my neighborhood
like it was so many people that was more
talented
as far as rapping
what did you say do you want me to cry
again god dude
[Applause]
it starts with you man you wake up from
the moon you land on some stars
you know how about that when i get off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son